hi I'm Erik Bosse and the vengers end
game released a new trailer 30 whole
seconds of footage into those who say
that's hardly enough to talk about you
don't watch trailers the way I do like a
paranoid shut-in who perceives this
simulated reality in the language of
Easter egg shaped computer code you know
I think there's a lot more here than it
seems mysterious inconsistencies cryptic
visual clues something in caps mouth
yeah probably survivor's guilt I'm gonna
break down everything you might have
missed frame by frame and before we
begin thank you to our sponsor Wix Wix
allows you to build your own
professional website we actually use Wix
to build up an interactive website for
you guys to get more involved in our
operation here more details on that
later and spoiler warning in case any of
this speculation ends up being right and
ruins your precious life let's get
started okay this trailer opens with a
super quick two-second montage of Marvel
heroes and already there's a lot going
on here these are all heroes whom danos
killed an infinity war and notice how
they all specifically go pretty much in
reverse order from the sequence we saw
them dust first wasp hope Van Dyne among
the most recent round of Dusty's in the
post-credits scene of ant-man in the
wasp
she's depicted here in the moment when
Hank Pym first unveiled her wasp suit in
the post-credits scene of the first
ant-man movie second Nick Fury the last
dusty in the final frames of the
post-credits scene after infinity war
wait was that the last time last right
thanks this shot is fury stepping off
the chopper to check in on the tesseract
in the opening scene of the first
Avengers movie next is spider-man the
final Avenger to dust during infinity
war this shot is during spider-man's
awesome MCU debut in civil war the
moment he snatched cap shield right
before Peters dusty and infinity war was
Doctor Strange so he's next in this
sequence in this shot is from the scene
in the Doctor Strange movie when he
suits up with a cloak of levitation now
next in the order would be the guardians
on Titan star-lord Drax and mantas but
here the trailer kind of groups them
with Groot later so next we get Falcon
depicted right after his cool barrel
roll move in Lagos in civil war then
Scarlet Witch who dusted right before
Falcon did here she's defending vision
against Corvus glaive and Proxima
midnight in the Edinburgh train station
and an infinity war and then we get the
guardians of the galaxy no mantas but
Gamora
is here this is from the moment they
escape the kiln prison in the first
guardians movie and right before a group
Dustin infinity war it with two chala so
he's next here we see him in the Black
Panther movie the moment he was flanked
by the dorm Elijah as he makes his way
into Cherise lab and before it's solid I
stood the first victim we saw of course
was Bucky whom we see next to the shot
from Winter Soldier when he caught caps
shield and finally there's vision whom
Thanos killed right before the snap his
shot here is from the end of the age of
Ultron right before his final
confrontation with Ultron in sokovia
and obviously they made all these shots
monochromatic but leaving the bright
color red in each frame this matches the
color palette of the Marvel Studios ten
title card but it also gives some point
at sea to each of these deaths it's like
when reflects the blood that was spilled
as each of these people faded into
neutral color dust it also reminds me of
the famous use of the color red by
Steven Spielberg and Schindler's List
the girl in the red coat during the
ghetto massacre sequence in that movie
this one splash of red in a world of
black and white served as a microcosm of
the widespread genocide and maybe this
moment is making a similar statement
about the genocide that these characters
are victims of and if I haven't already
overanalyze this enough we should point
out that red is also the color of the
reality stone I just mentioned this
because one popular theory out there is
that maybe these characters aren't dead
like maybe they were just separated into
another reality where these guys are
still alive in the survivors of infinity
war the ones who are dead and maybe the
red reality stone is a key to unlocking
the door to that parallel reality only
chew on that as we move on to some
actual footage from this movie and boy
is it bleak the fog that has settled
over New York City makes it look as
though the city's skyline is in the
process of dusting away as well there's
a grim shot of the Statue of Liberty
with hundreds of boats docked around
Liberty Island now normally Liberty
Island has just two piers to bury
tourists and staff to and from the
island maybe all of these boats are like
ghost ships with each of their crews
having dusted away while they're on the
water and then they drifted ashore to
the island or maybe all these boats were
a part of a search and rescue operation
for people looking for others who are
stranded overseas whatever this is it
tells us that a good amount of time has
passed at least a few months since the
destination and by the way decimation is
the official name of the dusting
snapping the snap sure whatever you want
to call it even though technically
decimation refers to 10% being affected
and thanos of course wiped out 50% of
living creatures but it's interesting to
see the consequences of this on the
Marvel world here I hope the movie
spends a lot of time in this
post-apocalyptic landscape actually in
another video I explored the real-world
effects that Thanos to snap would have
had on our society and infrastructure
definitely go check it out but I should
remind you all that 50% isn't 50%
uniformly everywhere like it doesn't
mean that exactly half of every city
half of every country half of every
planet is Dawne like thanasis nap was
supposedly random and billions of coin
flips would theoretically adhere to law
of averages but you could possibly end
up with like 90% of New Yorkers dusting
and every single resident of Florida
surviving unaffected look my home state
just finds a way to ruin everything we
also see Citi Field home of the Mets
Citi Field is a dark pit of despair it
also looks pretty sad in this trailer
but notice those cars in a parking lot
you can see how the traffic wedged up as
people panicked and fled perhaps trying
to get home to check on loved ones or to
try to get to a dry cleaner to get
Mickey Callaway's dust out of their
clothes I've been talking a lot so let's
be one of those people that moves on
that cap talks it out move on
[Applause]
okay so after city filled we move on to
this group therapy session another
example of the way society has been
affected by the snap there's a poster
advertising this therapy with the slogan
where do we go now that they're gone
the idea that people are doing this
reminds me a lot of the world of the
leftovers the HBO series and the novel
which was set in the aftermath of a
similar rapture style event that caused
2% of the world's population to
disappear many the characters took part
in similar therapy programs and in some
cases bizarre self therapy in cult
communities it'll be interesting to
Steve endgame explores those
consequences but notice how this poster
features a solitary figure with a row of
shadows of absent figures maybe it's
just me but for me these kind of evoke
those eerie nuclear shadows that were
imprinted on surfaces after the atomic
explosions and Hiroshima and Nagasaki
it became haunting memories of the
victims who were caught in these blast
waves
similarly the victims of fantasies
snapped destination leave nothing behind
but of shadows a pile of dust and
residue now this facility looks like a
VFW hall and cap join in this session
could be a nod to the group therapy
sessions that Sam used to run for vets
and Winter Soldier Captain Lee appears
to be biting his tongue here bottling up
an anger and restlessness that he can't
quite express this way he doesn't want
to move on because he probably still
feels like he has blood on his hands and
the voice over here expresses his
thoughts exactly
some people move on but not us now I
guess we're meant to assume that this is
caps voice but if you listen closely
only part of it really sounds like in
the first part sounds to me more like
Tony Stark
some people move on yeah maybe I'm
hearing things maybe this audio is just
for a promo and won't be in the final
movie or maybe this is from seen when
cap and Stark reunite and we see a way
that might happen in the next shot Tony
and nebula previously shown stranded
adrift on the Guardian ship the Bennett
are now science and the stat of this it
looks like Tony Stark has gone full
circle remember in the first Ironman he
rescued himself from captivity by
engineering a solution building a suit
in a cave with the box of scraps and now
the box of scraps his name Nebula check
it out she appears to be prying a
partner mechanical hand perhaps Lindy
and Tony a literal
and as he repairs the ship this would be
a nice callback to how Thanos dismissed
nebula an infinity war would have been a
waste of part yeah here's a good use of
parts yet dick the most interesting
thing to me about this shot it's Tony
look at the arc reactor in his chest
infinity war his new nanotech armor
appeared to be part of or maybe on top
of his clothes
but now the arc reactor definitely glows
from under his shirt
it looks like it's once again embedded
in his chest does this mean Tony Stark
has reimplantation side his flesh it
really does bring him back full circle
over the cave and before I move on but
not emotionally it's impossible to move
on emotionally for me there's this shot
of CAP nataschab banner and Rhodey
outside Avengers HQ looking upward at
something now I'm not that great at
reading faces according to various
specialists and online tests but I would
describe their looks as concerned or
confused or surprised what is making
them feel these feels well we know that
Thor and Rocket are among the heroes
left on earth so maybe one of them is
taking off in the middle of the night to
try to find Thanos go off on his own or
maybe they're just you know sick of
sitting around moping or maybe these
four are walking up to the arrival of
someone or something like maybe Stark
and nebula returning to earth on the
benitar or maybe captain marvel arriving
or maybe one of the many cosmic entities
that we've speculated might engage in
some kind of divine intervention with
the Avengers characters like The Living
Tribunal or eternity or Chronos now
judging from their clothes this shot is
taking place around the same time cap
and Natasha saw that video feed of Scott
Lang at the front gate maybe they're
walking out to the gate to greet Scott
so they can find out where the hell he's
been or when the hell he's been
check out my earlier breakdown for my
theory of how time travel could play a
role in this and there might be
something else that we missed in this
shot but I want to talk more about that
later for now onto the next clip
yes okay so this last section begins
with a quick shot of rockets coming
through a door now a few things here
first look at his outfit rockets new
clothes are the blue buttons jumpsuit
that he wears in the 2008 guardians of
the galaxy comics ones by Dan Abnett and
Andy Lanning
but more importantly some clues in the
background might tell us where he is
there's a rocky coastline and some
lobster traps lying around to me this
suggests this is somewhere in the
northern Atlantic my guess Norway the
reason I think that is there's another
shot in this section showing Thor in
some structure facing some steep green
hills some have suggested he could be on
Titan to the planet Thanos design at the
end of infinity war maybe in or near
Thanos's farmhouse or maybe Thor's in
Wakanda but I think rocket and Thor are
in the same place and that Thor has
exiled himself somewhere on this
Norwegian coast because that is the
homeland of Norse mythology and it's the
location where his father Odin died and
maybe here rocket has tracked down for
two beggin to come back or maybe own son
and rabbit are staying teamed up after
infinity war to search for thinness on
their own because they're stubborn and
they refuse to give up so the two of
them shack up in this lobster hut Norway
we also see Natasha Banting some steam
on a firing range and Avengers HQ on the
right you can see she's already shredded
through the bullseye on one of them and
she's working her way down but notice
that where her hair is tied in a braid
and it's much longer than the length
that we saw in other shots for it to
grow from that to this it would take at
least six months according to my
girlfriend who knows more about these
things than I do maybe longer than six
months
look it is hard to gauge the timeline
here but for Liberty Island to turn into
a shipyard for post snap support groups
to start up and Black Widow to grow
braid I think there's a good chance
we'll see some time jump maybe six
months later but again if time travel or
parallel timeline jumping comes into
play in this movie hair length might not
indicate anything there's also this shot
of ant-man and Brody's suiting up and
Avengers HQ so this tells us that Scott
will end up with them in the present
regardless of whether or not the video
feed was archive footage but also that
some kind of action will heat up right
from the Avengers home base also this
looks like new war machine armor
remember--the Anna's disabled the armor
that Rhodey used an infinity war and
while he could still walk around and
then it wouldn't be an effective weapon
unless
banner rocket helped him repair it or
unless stark left behind an upgrade for
him this could also be how Pepper Potts
gets a suit of armor like the one that
we've seen when it pouch were wearing
and set photos we also briefly see
Hawkeye he looks like he's in some kind
of crash site crater like you could see
smoke and crumbling debris maybe the red
light on his face is from a vessel that
crashed there maybe it's whatever the
other Avengers were looking up at in
that other shot Clint also appears to be
feeling deals next there's this close-up
of cap tightening his shield few things
here first cap has his old shield back
remember he hasn't had it since his
fight with Stark and Civil War and even
then that was a newer upgrade with a
magnetic controls if I remember
correctly whereas this one looks to be
the classic one with leather straps in
spider-man homecoming remember happy
Hogan did mention Stark was working on a
new shield for cap but this one doesn't
look like a new prototype it's a relic
we'll see but this could be another clue
pointing toward cap going retro and
fighting his old battles maybe there's
some form of time travel but notice is
dirty trembling hands very dramatic this
reminded me of another Spielberg shot
also of a world war ii soldier the
recurring close-up and Saving Private
Ryan Shelley Tom Hanks is shaking hand
it was a way of expressing the
characters humanity despite his steady
outward demeanour so I'm guessing that
this shot could be from caps final bout
with Thanos perhaps something like that
face to face fight that they went
through in the Infinity Gauntlet comics
and next we get a very interesting shot
of the heroes marching through Avengers
HQ as the Sun rises
there's cap Thor Black Widow rocket
ant-man war machine and right behind
Rhodey banner but what's weird to me is
that we already saw this same shot same
framing and everything in the last
trailer except the room was empty so why
would they shoot these same shot twice
once with actors and once without it
could be a lot of reasons but I have two
theories first maybe this is just one of
many examples of footage shown in a
trailer that ends up getting re-edited
or dropped in the final cut of the movie
like that one big Avengers are simple
shot from the infinity war trailer that
was never in the movie at all like they
might have a lot of versions of this
shot because they have a lot of CGI to
do on it like obviously rocket had to be
CGI inserted but notice that gap
and the line between Scott and rody will
the Russos later digitally insert
another character in there like maybe
Hawkeye and coming back to that shot on
the lawn earlier notice the empty space
between Boehner and Brody does rody just
not like walking next to other people
I mean sure sometimes you just gotta
walk off a fart right or maybe the
Avengers plan to insert Hawkeye or
another character like Captain Marvel or
Pepper Potts and rescue armor or some
other new character something spoilery
in those empty spaces in the final cut
okay so that's theory one theory too is
that this dolly shot is telling more of
a story than we realize look at the
position of the Sun it's a bit higher in
the first trailer shot the one without
people in it and that shot is also
moving to the left as opposed to this
one which is moving right could the
different positions of the Sun in the
different camera movements be important
clues here look there's been a lot of
evidence pointed to some kind of cosmic
displacement for these heroes like
traveling back in time traveling to a
parallel reality traveling somewhere
this displacement could be connected to
the devices that we've seen on the
Avengers hands set photos imagine that
these two sunrise shots are actually
part of the same moment the camera
follows the Avengers as they march
across the room right as the Sun rises
and then they disappear or displace back
in time into another reality somewhere
then as they disappear the camera
dollies back across the now empty room
then after their displacement they march
back into this moment at the end of
their journey maybe different characters
are with them it would be like if you're
in Back to the Future and you're just
another character standing in the Twin
Pines mall parking lot and they see
Marty McFly drive the DeLorean out of
1985 disappear into the past and then
moments later he returns back from the
past and does that random roll down the
bushes like I know this is the theory
and to be honest I'm really just leaning
toward this being part of the abundance
of excess footage at the Russo shot for
the movie and use just for the trailers
won't be in the movie and that's why
there are these duplicate versions but
I'll give you one last possible clue
listen to what we hear during this shot
now this is kind of weird because we
already heard cap say not us earlier in
the trailer some people move on the -
why would cap say not us twice for
dramatic effect like switches final
words in the matrix like this not like
this yeah dramatic effect possibly
probably but listen again to the two
back to back they're different about us
yes yeah see the second not us there's
gotta be more than just an echo like it
sounds deeper more of a growl some are
saying it kind of sounds like Ultron I
don't know about that but maybe the
reason we here - not buses is that
they're coming from - cats what a
present one past or one in reality a one
in reality be like I know I'm reaching
here that's kind of my job because
sometimes these big theory swings get
you a dinger all the way to the empty
bleachers of Citi field's here's what I
want to know from you if those empty
spaces are going to be filled by a
mystery character who do you want it to
be and which of these shots do you think
could end up just being a trailer only
footage for this promo comment down
below with your thoughts and follow me
on twitter and instagram at a vas and
subscribe to this channel and subscribe
to our new podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts and little plug here if you
live in the LA area come meet me every
first Friday of the month at the Acme
theatre in North Hollywood for my live
comedy show darkest timeline comedy and
again big thanks to our sponsor Wix Wix
allows you to build a professional
website with thousands of easy-to-use
templates that set you up with a site
for whatever you need it to be like
every functioning adult needs a legit
place for people to find them online
with a platform that you controlled that
does what you need it to do a vlog
business a place to show off your
projects new rockstars actually used Wix
to build a website of our own you go
check it out thanks to Wix we now have
one place where you have a direct line
to us to give us feedback and help us
decide what kinds of videos to make all
in a way that we can actually hear and
you don't get buried in tweets and
comments sections and we've actually
started using this feedback they've
given us through this Wix site to decide
what types of videos to make in 2019 so
you can help us keep this discussion
going when it comes to design Wix gives
you infinite possibilities to make your
website your own unique masterpiece but
Wix takes care of all the heavy lifting
your site will be safe secure and you
don't have to worry about weird
Lich's that could have come up if you
tried to build a site without someone
helping you Wix has a solution for every
need with features like Wix blog links
video which stores Wix booking really
anything you need a website to improve
your life Wix has you covered build your
own website today by going to wix.com
slash go slash new rock stars or by
using our link in the description below
thank you for watching shout out to my
buddy Alex NoHo and hey we still got a
couple months plenty of time to
digitally insert this guy next to the
Avengers I'm told I'm great at
expressing ambiguous emotion oh look
guys a thing I feel feelings